The way he was taken was not the America that
I know
like our own government basically kidnapped
my dad
and it was, it terrified me.
Early on a Sunday morning in late May
Jose Garcia was walking to his car to grab
a coffee mug
when several armed agents in bulletproof vests
approached and told him he was under arrest.
They just grabbed me by the shoulders and
I asked them
can you please let me talk to my daughter, my wife.
They said no and I started screaming to Natalie.
I started hearing him scream out for my name
and so I ran out, like three agents stopped me,
didn't identify themselves so I didn't know
who they were.
Natalie Garcia eventually realized that the
agents who arrested her father
were with Immigration and Customs Enforcement,
ICE.
His arrest was part of an ICE sweep that had
picked up 162 people
including at least 8 green card holders like
Garcia.
And I had never expected ICE to take my parent
because my dad has legal status.
Her dad was a lawful permanent resident
who'd lived in Southern California for more than 50 years
and raised children, grand children and great
grand children there.
I come to America for the American dream and
build a family as well.
You can actually get whatever you want when
you work hard.
ICE targeted Garcia based on a 17 year old
domestic violence misdemeanor
which he says happened when a neighbor called
the police
after overhearing an argument between him
and his wife.
The courthouse didn't retain any documents
describing the incident in any further detail.
But Garcia's guilty plea in 2001 made him
technically eligible for deportation.
At the time of Garcia's arrest, national attention
was focused
on the family separation crisis at the US
Mexico border.
Protesters railed against the Trump administration
action that separates children
from parents accused of violating immigration
laws.
I have put in place a zero tolerance policy
for illegal entry on our southwest border.
And soon Garcia's case began to receive national
attention.
Natalie found herself standing at the center
of a media storm and defending her father.
They should not even be separating families.
I became the poster child for this whole entire
situation.
I'm a private person in general, being in
front of the camera
it was never something that I wanted to do.
But the more that I was the more that know
it was helping my father.
She told me she was going to get me out of
there.
And I believed in her and I knew she was going
to do it one way or the other.
The judge granted Jose's case during the very
first hearing
a highly unusual move according to his Los
Angeles based immigration attorney Mickenzy Mackens.
The fact that mister Garcia's case was granted
at the first court hearing is extraordinary.
I think the judge and the government attorney
were effected
by the fact that there was so much community
support for mister Garcia
and media attention on the case, I think it
helped.
After three weeks in jail, he was free again.
At 11 0 clock tonight the family finally reunited
but as you can imagine it's been a long few
weeks for them.
When he called out my name the first time
he was arrested
it was like I was called to finish this, like
to help him
and once everything got resolved it was like
I could breathe again.
Mister Garcia's case is just once example
of many
where people who are members of our community,
hard workers,
have been picked up by ICE and targeted for
reasons that are beyond comprehension
for most Americans.
Donald Trump ran for president on the promise
of ridding the country of illegal immigrants.
We will begin removing the more than 2 million
criminal illegal immigrants from the country.
Five days after being sworn in as president
he began making good on that promise
by signing an executive order directing ICE
to begin targeting all removable aliens
living in the country.
The Department of Homeland Security followed
suit
by releasing a memo rescinding much of the
discretion that ICE agents, prosecutors and judges
were previously allowed to exercise in prosecuting
cases.
The administration has basically unshackled
ICE, given it free reign to do whatever it wants
and said no group is off limits.
Alex Nowrasteh is an immigration policy analyst
at the CATO Institute.
He says the administration's policies are
an escalation of what began during the Obama years.
When Obama came into office and until 2012
he was rightfully known as the deporter in chief.
He basically broke every deportation record
no matter how you measure it.
Now beginning about 2012, he started to roll
it back,
the deportation numbers are still not up to
what they were
for the first several years of the Obama administration.
And it's my prediction they will never get
up there again.
While arrests at the border have actually
decreased since trump took office,
ICE arrests from the interior of the country
increased by 30% between 2016 and 2017.
Trump's executive order means that they're
basically trying to draft
every police officer in the country into being an immigration enforcer,
while also increasing the amount of power
that the federal agents already have.
It's sort of an effort to roll back the clock
in a sense
to go back to the way that immigration enforcement
was
during the first 3 to 4 years of the Obama
administration
and to really go back to that deporter in
chief mode.
Mackins also represents Sergio Quiroz,
a 23 year old man who came over the border
with his mother when he was 7 months old
and has lived in the US ever since.
As a kid I knew I came from Hispanic parents
and a family you know
but I felt like I was American you know 'cause
my first language was English.
Quiroz ran into trouble with immigration enforcement
after getting into a fight with his ex girlfriend in 2017
he says he grabbed and threw her iphone.
His court disposition says he admitted to
'unlawfully and willfully touching another
person' which qualifies as simple battery.
The misdemeanor itself is not a deportable
offence
but ICE has increasingly used what are called
detainers
to pick up undocumented immigrants like Quiroz
from local jails.
I was in county for a month approximately
and after that
when I was getting released the same night
immigration came for me and took me down to
San Diego to the federal.
I was just like very overwhelmed because there's
been guys in there that have been for like ten years.
That's why so many states and localities do
not cooperate with ICE detainers.
They see ICE detainers as a way to cast a
wide net
to arrest people who should not be deported.
Quiroz is now in removal proceedings and has
to do regular check ins with ICE.
When I think about getting deported I would
have to live with the doubt and fear
that I may get executed or robbed or something
may happen to me out there
cause I'm just a complete stranger, it's pretty
scary you know.
In the same way that I think all of us would be repelled by the sense
that somebody was accused of shoplifting say
20 dollars worth of merchandise
and their punishment would be to be removed
from the country that they know and love
to be separated from all their human relationships
and their property
we'd all realize that that was a grossly disproportionate
punishment to the offence.
And that is exactly what I'd say about this.
The administration often talks about cracking
down on criminals and dangerous gangs like MS13.
These are animals , they're coming into our
country, we're getting them out,
they come in again, we're getting them out.
So Garcia's arrest shows just how little ICE
has to do
and how little actual threat from illegal
immigrants is from a national security
and public safety perspective.
That they have to target somebody with a 17
year old offense
that they have to target folks like him shows
just how safe the situation is
and how small the public safety threat is
from immigrants.
When Trump got into office he made it seem
like he was going after the cartels,
the drug lords, the gang members and everything
and who he's actually going after and what
he's doing he's deceiving his own supporters
to be honest with you.
And mister Trump has got to change his policy,
he's got to do something about it.
I still like this man, I thought he was going
to do a better job but he's doing, he don't do-
to this point he's not doing a good job.
ICE officials declined interview requests
for this story
but Nawrasteh says the justice department's
policy
of removing discretion from ICE agents, prosecutors
and judges
has exacerbated the problems of America's
overtaxed immigration system.
The administration is trying to charge anyone
it possibly can with an immigration offense
and the maximum offense possible.
The problem with this is that this clogs up
the court system dramatically
I mean there are almost 800,000 court cases
pending in the immigration court
prior to Jeff Sessions earlier in 2018 announcing
that they're gonna prosecute every border crosser
so the likely numbers now are probably above
a million in terms of backlog cases.
The problem with that is that the courts are
so backlogged that they can't really clear anything.
So even if ICE arrests a lot of people.
they're going to be sitting in immigration
detention,
they're going to be out there on bond, they're
going to be out there on ankle bracelets
so they're really just not gonna be able to
ramp up this deportation machine.
Several prominent Democrats have called for
the complete abolition of ICE
which has existed since 2003.
In order for us to feel safer in our streets,
our churches, our schools and our homes
we must abolish ICE.
I believe you should get rid of it, start
over, re-imagine it.
The abolish ICE movement is mostly just an
optical one, of propaganda and phrase and slogan.
The problem is if you abolish ICE now
and you do not change any of the other immigration
laws that are on the books
another law enforcement agency is just gonna
do the same thing
they're going to do it in probably about the
same way
and you've really accomplished nothing.
Rather than focusing on ICE, Nawrasteh suggest
abolishing actual immigration crimes,
such as illegal border crossings, and treating
such an act like a civil infraction
akin to a parking ticket rather than a criminal offence.
And he advocates abolishing Enforcement and
Removal Operations or ERO, a division of ICE.
Two thirds of ERO's arrests are for non criminal
offenses or victim-less crimes.
Abolishing ERO would leave interior enforcement
duties with Homeland Security Investigations or HSI.
Which he says should only focus on violent
criminals and national security threats.
Doing that won't abolish ICE but what it will
do is get rid of the worst parts of ICE
and preserve the portions that I think should
exist.
100% of ICE resources should be focused on
removing national security,
violent and property criminals.
Abolishing ERO and focusing entirely on HSI
would accomplish that goal.
Sergio Quiroz and his mother continue to fight
his removal order.
As for Jose Garcia, he's back with his family
but plans to finally obtain full citizenship
to protect himself going forward.
To me this is my country and I love it and
I want to stay here for the longest I can.
I want to be buried over here when the time
comes.